For example, if we have packets arriving in this queue destined
for the orange queue, at the front of the queue, then
even with the speed up, there may be packets that are
sufficiently far behind in the queue that they're waiting behind the
orange packets. What we'd like to be able to do is
perform matchings to allow these packets to be sent to the
output ports, and not have to wait for the entire queue
to be drained of packets destined for the orange output port.
A solution is to create virtual output queues, where instead of having a single
queue at the input, we have one queue per output port. This prevents packets
at the front of the queue that are destined for a particular output port
from blocking packets that could otherwise be
matched to other output queues in earlier timeslots.